personally I cringe every time I hear
the word illegal I don't think that
people realize that the first illegal
immigrants were European settlers we're
still here and we care about what's
going on with indigenous people being
left out of the immigration conversation
it it makes me feel forgotten it almost
makes us as a people still feel like we
are non-existent if we're going to talk
about illegal immigration we need to go
back in the last 350 to 500 years ago of
starting with Plymouth Rock and who had
permission to come over to our lands
I even feel uncomfortable seeing an
immigrant my ancestors you know long
long time ago didn't have those concepts
it is very ironic and very frustrating
that the people who are imposing their
right-wing beliefs and they're very like
Don check his stance on immigration
calling you know our family's illegal
and trying to push these borders upon us
weren't the original people of this land
anyway
if we're going to talk about enforcing
you know stricter regulations around the
border and enforcing Border Patrol than
what does that mean for those
reservations that are split and those
tribes that are split by the border
there are several Native people
communities that live along the
us-mexico border and several of them
their lands are divided by the border
and that's my people too we don't think
of the people who are south of the
border who are coming up you know for a
better life as indigenous people just
because time has continued to go on and
these borders have been created and
different policies to hinder some of
that movement it doesn't mean that the
people innately are going to stop
there's such things as sacred sites as
places of worship and places that are
culturally and historically important
for people that live along the us-mexico
border
these u.s. imposed borders have a real
physical effect on our families on our
way of life on our traditions on our
culture everything from gathering foods
to practicing ceremonies I think that
what is important for indigenous voices
is that we speak up
and that we realize that we're not
foreigners on our own land regardless of
what borders are there America doesn't
belong to anybody it's just a plot of
land that all of us as human people were
just here to to be stewards of the land
the land is our sorry it's it's our
earth it's our it's our medicine to us
it's our mother
right
I didn't think that I was going to hit
me this hard until HSS